entre autres par monsieur maurice
schumann le ministre des affaires
étrangères devait faire le bilan de la
visite que vient de faire à paris hier
et avant-hier le nouveau premier
ministre de suède monsieur olof palme
qui est ce monsieur olof palme qui
deviendra peut-être un partenaire
important de la france si les projets
d'élargissement du marché commun
aboutisse eh bien nous vous proposons de
le découvrir un peu mieux grâce à ce
portrait que nous avons réalisés depuis
le 2 octobre 1969 sur les axes en une
musique de chopin choisi pour son titre
la révolutionnaire olof palme 1 42 ans
est désigné à la majorité par le congrès
social-démocrate pour succéder à taguer
irlande air leader du parti et premier
ministre démissionnaire après une panne
six ans au pouvoir
ce jeune promis du socialisme que l'on
qualifie déjà de kennedy européens aux
allures de citoyens jacobins bien élevé
le st juste scandinaves aux yeux gris
bleus perçants dont on ne trouve
l'équivalent que dans le reflet de la
cie suédois ce patricien rouge peu
conventionnelle est en retard pour
prendre possession de son nouveau bureau
que uytsel en toute simplicité son
prédécesseur monsieur tigerland heures
on
on était 68 les manifestations
d'étudiants n'épargne pas la suède
olof palme est alors ministre de
l'éducation ouvre le dialogue avec les
contestataires dans leur fief même la
maison des étudiants sifflé à son
arrivée il ne mâche pas ses mots
selon certains les étudiants seraient à
eux seuls les éléments potentiels
capables de transformer la société
mais je ne partage pas cet avis étudiant
aujourd'hui leaders de demain n'est que
de la démagogie réactionnaire des
étudiants ne sont qu'un des gros qui
potentiellement peuvent changer la
société et je suis étranger à toute
société délit et élites intérieures
quel est votre salaire mensuel par an je
sais c'est appeler au plus mais ce sont
1000 que l'on naît comme mentalement 50
me plaît et vous puis combien d'impôts à
peu près son nez dans vos impôts
oui 'nos 4 oui sans son sur cent mille
couronnes de non seules 150 microns je
pèse un peu plus que son écot